Was mich sehr erstaunt hat
und erschrocken hat,
ist, dass doch sehr viele Leute
auch aus dem nahen Umfeld
einem dann den Rücken kehren.
Also klar, man ist vorher der Held,
wenn Investoren kommen
– aber dann wenn‘s dann
eben mal zu Ende ist,
dann ist es auch bei einigen Freunden,
wo ich wirklich auch sehr überrascht war,
die ich schon lange vor der Gründung
von Carzapp kannte,
aus gewesen mit der Freundschaft.
Oliver Lünstedt ist mit seinem
Start-Up pleitegegangen.
Er hat einen digitalen
Schlüssel erfunden,
mit dem lassen sich per
Smartphone Autos öffnen.
Herkömmliche Wagen können
damit nachgerüstet werden.
Für seine Innovation heimste
er mehrere Preise ein,
trotzdem ging ihm nach vier
Jahren das Geld aus
– und das hat ihn gezeichnet.
Es war erst mal ein ziemlicher Schock
auf nem Freitagabend Ende November,
wo wir erfahren haben,
dass das Investment,
was eigentlich schon in
trockenen Tüchern war
und die Verträge ausgehandelt waren,
dass das nicht kommen wird,
wo sich jemand spontan umentschieden hat.
Dann ging es los, dass man versucht hat,
auf schnellstem Wege zu gucken:
Gibt es noch Möglichkeiten,
irgendwoher Geld zu bekommen?
Anderthalb Millionen Euro hat er verbrannt:
Geld vom Serverbetreiber,
von Investoren und Bekannten.
Zehn Mitarbeiter musste er entlassen.
Auf Messen für Firmengründer wird
kaum über das Scheitern gesprochen.
Hier herrscht grenzenloser Optimismus,
obwohl neun von zehn Start-Ups in
Deutschland erfahrungsgemäß missglücken.
Wer scheitert wie Oliver Lünstedt,
schweigt lieber darüber,
doch der Wirtschaftsingenieur geht
offen mit seinem Fehlschlag um.
Wir hätten das Produkt früher an den
echten Kundenbedarf anpassen müssen:
Also wir haben zu lange in die
Richtung entwickelt, in der wir dachten,
dass der Kunde es haben möchte,
und haben zu spät gemerkt,
dass der Markt eigentlich in ‚ner ganz
anderen Ecke für uns liegt
und wir pivotieren, wie man sagt, also
die Strategie wechseln sollten.
Tobias Zumbült ist sogar
zweimal gescheitert –
trotzdem meidet man
ihn nicht in der Geschäftswelt.
Meine Kunden, die ich jetzt habe,
die schätzen, was ich weiß,
und sehen es nicht als
Stigma oder als Malus.
Also, die Angst ist jetzt unbegründet, also
dass man auch mal offen darüber redet?
Im professionellen Bereich
ist es unbegründet,
im gesellschaftlichen ist es schon so,
dass ich von Freunden und Familie
auch die Frage bekomme:
Also du bist gescheitert
und berätst jetzt andere?
Also du bist mit
‘nem Unternehmen gescheitert
und berätst andere Unternehmen? Das geht
doch nicht. Aber es geht, es geht sehr gut.
Solche Erfahrungen
nehmen jungen Menschen
die Angst vor der Selbstständigkeit.
Ja, dass es wahrscheinlich gar
nicht so schlimm ist zu scheitern,
dass es mehr Mut erfordert
erst mal anzufangen
und dann kann man ja
weitergucken, wie es läuft
und ja vielleicht dann
doch diesen … dieses Wagnis eingehen.
Und es ist gar nicht so schlimm,
die Leute leben noch
und offenbar sind die
auch ganz glücklich.
Ich hab daraus gelernt, dass ich
nicht so viel Risiko vielleicht eingehe,
so was vielleicht Geldaufnahme
betrifft, und versuche,
so wenig wie möglich
Fremdkapital aufzunehmen.
Wenn ein Wille da ist, man
für die Idee kämpft
und wirklich auch
Durchhaltevermögen beweist,
dann kann man schon viel bewegen.
Oliver Lünstedt hat eine
neue Firma gegründet.
Mittlerweile kann er auch
Bürotüren digital öffnen.
Den Neustart wagte er in
einem Berliner Gründerzentrum,
finanziert unter anderem
mit den Ersparnissen seiner Mutter.
350 Euro Miete zahlt er hier.
Das Budget ist auch sonst schmal,
dafür schreibt seine neue Firma
von Anfang an schwarze Zahlen.
Das ist jetzt das erste Mal,
dass wir und dass ich
auch wirklich ich sag mal
beruhigt schlafen kann,
sagen kann: Auch in zwei, drei Monaten
muss ich mir nicht die Sorgen machen,
wo kommt das Geld her, um die Miete,
die Mitarbeiter, ihre Gehälter zu bezahlen.
Das ist insofern deutlich entspannter.
Für das weitere Wachstum will er
demnächst den Nachbarraum anmieten.
Er will drei zusätzliche
Mitarbeiter einstellen.
Zu den Kunden gehören
inzwischen ein Autovermieter
ebenso wie die Deutsche Telekom.
Die Pleite steckt ihm noch
immer in den Knochen,
doch der Traum vom erfolgreichen
eigenen Unternehmen
scheint nun endlich wahr zu werden.